Thompson:
Now we're on. Okay.
Google APIs.
Imagine trying to deploy
services like these
on your own.
The levels of redundancy,
the years of development.
I used to struggle
for the budget
to get a second server,
even for mission-critical
applications.
But thousands--
tens of thousands
of companies
still operate that way.
And eventually they'll become
a really huge market
for transitions to the cloud.
I've been given
a lot of opportunities
to learn things
while working with Google.
I've signed some severe
confidentiality agreements.
I really can't blog anymore.
Can't publish anything.
Can't talk in my sleep.
But I can share this.
I know Google's passionate
about performance
and reliability.
If you can come up
with something
that shaves ten milliseconds
off an operation,
there's cheers all around.
I've never seen
anything like it.
So that's one of the reasons
I would say I think Google's
the long-term best candidate
to be the cloud,
their APIs.
There'll be others
in narrow niches,
but Google
will be the gold standard.
And learning to make good use
of the Google APIs
is a competitive advantage,
'cause right now, for the price
of an email address,
on App Engine,
we can have ten
of our own virtual servers.
Each one can handle
7,400 requests per minute
through a ten-gig pipeline.
It's hard to compete
against that kind of--
it's hard to compete
with those kinds
of free resources
if you didn't have them.
This is a short list
of what we consider to be
essential API tools.
For us, the basics
are App Engine,
Base, Gadgets, Maps,
and Spreadsheets.
If we get good with these,
we can cover a lot of ground.
Probably a lot of you know
these APIs better than I do.
And I'm not here
because I'm some kind
of expert on anything.
I think the reason I'm here
is 'cause I've been
in the industry so long,
and I just work really hard,
and I work like crazy.
So I'm probably
telling you some things--
Maybe you already knew that.
And hopefully,
there'll be something in here
that you can take away
that'll be helpful to you.
But I'll go through it.
Google Base lets us put
just about any kind
of content online.
And, again, for the price
of an email address,
we can put
1 million records online.
Lots of major companies
already have their products
on Google Base.
So when it's time
to make an ad for them,
we need to understand
how to get their items
from Google Base.
Plenty of clients
still have their own APIs,
but Base is
an important one to know.
In my case,
Google Gadgets
are the most certain way
to generate traffic.
Last year--Or last March,
just from Google Gadgets,
it generated a million visitors
on my Websites,
over 19 million page views,
and it was all free traffic.
Didn't have to pay
for any of it.
Gadgets are also used as ads,
and we'll look at some examples
of those later.
Google Maps just keeps getting
better and better.
After seeing that keynote
and seeing
the Rasmussens in action,
I understand why
that's such a good API.
For me,
Google Spreadsheets
have become, like,
the Swiss Army Knife
of applications,
especially when we need,
like, a quick solution,
you know,
some small data set.
Just about every client
has somebody
that knows
how to use a spreadsheet.
Jerome will go
into a lot more details
about AdSense
and the affiliates.
YouTube has some
really neat API tricks.
Picasa, of course,
is great for handling images.
And Google Friend Connect,
it's about a year old.
Has anybody ever heard
or used Google Friend Connect?
I still run into people
who have never heard of it.
But basically,
it lets people
join your site,
and then
you can do persistence,
you know,
let them rate things,
have polls,
and it's very easy
to set up and do.
And they can log in
from other social services
other than just Google's.
We've broken monetization down
for our talk today
into two sections--
indirect and direct.
By direct,
we mean people paying us
to do certain things for them.
By indirect,
we mean the AdSense
and affiliate programs.
We won't be mentioning
some of the others,
since this is
a Google presentation,
like Amazon.
When working
directly for clients,
it's common to quote
an hourly rate,
and that's--
For us, that's a little bit
less attractive,
because it puts us
in competition
with every other programmer
in the world directly,
especially with
the low-cost labor markets.
When we started making
Gadget ads for Google,
they did want to pay us
by the hour,
and it made perfect sense,
because no one really knew
how long it would take
to do this.
We were doing things--
putting things together
that hadn't been done
quite that way before,
and one of the first
things I learned
is there's a huge difference
between making a gadget for fun
and making an ad.
An ad, the appearance
is absolutely fixed.
The tolerance
is plus or minus zero pixels.
You have to nail it exactly.
The first project I worked on
was a great one to learn from,
because it had
some classic challenges.
I think I was
the third developer.
I don't know what happened
to the first one.
The second one
said he was on vacation.
And the day I started,
we were over budget
and, like,
four weeks behind.
And the client
was communication challenged.
They would burn a whole week
between questions.
And when the answer
finally arrived,
it might be one sentence
in all caps--
"JUST MATCH THE MOCK-UP."
I also--When we started,
I tried to let
the Google folks know
I wasn't sure if I was
really professional enough
to deal with their clients
directly.
I'd had about, at that point,
about 25 years experience
dealing with
the table-pounders in Detroit,
but I'd never worked
with anybody
in the advertising
industry before,
and I imagined it would be
a lot different.
It turns out clients really--
or customers really
aren't that different
in the different industries.
And in advertising,
there's a lot--
there's less table pounding.
One point
about fixed-price bids
is they make it easier
for people to buy from you.
You always have to imagine
what it's like for your contact
to go get approval
to pay you to do something.
So if you're talking
in terms of an hourly rate,
it's almost like asking
for a blank check,
because, you know,
really don't know how long
it's gonna take,
and you can just say,
"Well, not
to exceed this much,"
or something like that.
But a fixed-price bid
makes it a lot easier for them
to go to their vice president
or whoever has to approve it
and say,
"Okay, we need X dollars
to do this project."
And then they can decide,
"Is it really worth it?"
You know, "Do we want to spend
that money on it?"
Okay, in our case,
connecting the markets is,
to me,
is the hardest part
of having your own business.
For us, we were really lucky.
Google reached out to us.
We had demonstrated
some proficiency with the APIs.
When the Gadget API was new,
actually, I started making
some gadgets,
kind of little games
and fun things,
to impress my daughters.
I might spend, like, a month
working on something,
getting it ready,
and they would be impressed
for about two minutes.
But after a while, you know,
it became challenging.
A lot of times I'd do things,
you know, "Can I do this?
Can we do that?"
And I started turning out
one or two gadgets a week.
And so when
they decided to, uh...
try to use Gadgets for ads,
they reached out to about
8 or 12 of us in that category
to find out
if we wanted to do it,
you know, for money,
to do it professionally.
I think one thing
I'd like to share,
you know,
throughout my life,
I've told people that...
Find what you love to do,
and do it with all your might.
And success
will follow from that.
And I think it's true.
It's true in our case.
I've also--I've--
Talk about building alliances,
I've been
in a lot of situations
where the customer/vendor
relationship
is adversarial.
Like it's a fight
all the time.
There's arguments,
dishonesty, and so forth.
What I found works better
is to try to make an alliance.
Try to find ways where everybody
comes out a winner,
and that they're really glad
they did business with you.
We have to keep
asking ourselves,
"Given the level
of service we're providing,
"would this customer
decide to do business
with us again?"
The early Gadget ad projects
were really hard for us,
because we
were putting things together
in ways
that hadn't been done before.
Clients would get anxious.
It would take three or four
tries to get something right.
I make so many mistakes.
One time it was late at night,
and we were working
on something.
We found out--you know,
we found out what to do,
and it meant
redoing a lot of code.
I mean, a lot,
and it was gonna take hours.
And I was chatting
with the contact at Google,
and I said,
"Okay, I'll start on it now,
and it'll be ready
in the morning."
And he chatted back.
He said,
"You're crazy, aren't you?"
And of course he was right,
but I think he meant it
in a good way.
But that's an example
of providing service
above and beyond what
their expectations might be.
Once you've connected
with the market
and you start doing
contract work,
an important point
is to manage
client expectations.
I learned that by watching
other people doing that.
I noticed they were doing that.
And I think
the important point there
is you don't want
to set the clients up
to be disappointed.
My natural tendency is to put
the very best spin on things,
and sometimes things
actually do work out
exactly perfect,
but usually not.
So it's better not
to set them up
to be disappointed.
More often--Oh.
More often than not,
the people who decide
to place contracts
aren't engineers themselves.
They're probably experts
at something else,
so you have to find out
how to communicate with them
at their comfort level.
One time
I was talking to a client,
and I said something
about the URL,
and he said, "Oh, whoa,
don't get all technical on me."
So you have to find out
where they're at
and work there.
I've seen sales guys
shoot themselves in the foot
by trying to wow the CEO
with the latest technical terms
and a lot of acronyms.
You know, he or she,
they're not gonna know
what that means.
And it just doesn't--
Bluffing just doesn't work
very well.
Estimating costs,
the only way I know to learn
to do it is to practice.
There's kind of
a laundry list there
of different things
you might think of
to take into account,
but the important part
is to practice.
I practiced estimating
how long is it gonna take me
to do this
even when it doesn't matter,
even if it's a project
I'm doing just for fun.
And what I found is,
for me,
about 25% of the total time
of a project,
about 25% I spent getting
to a working first draft,
and then about 50%
of the time
is for debugging
and meeting
all the requirements.
Sorry.
And the remaining 25%
is testing.
And of course, support goes on
till the last user is dead.
So the best way to learn
to estimate well is to practice.
Last year, one example,
I missed an estimate
literally by half.
And there were
some communication issues.
There were some open-ended areas
in the requirements,
and the client
interpreted them
completely differently
than I did.
So, you know, half pay
is better than no pay.
At least I got paid for it,
but the lesson learned
was to really nail down
the requirements
as well as I can.
Scheduling.
In our case,
most of the projects
are due yesterday.
So really all you can do
is level the work
as best you can.
Selling.
You know,
people will give you--
There's all kind of seminars
and books about selling.
They'll give you all kinds
of advice about it.
So don't take my word for it.
Shop around.
See what really works for you.
But this is what's always
worked for me.
For me,
the most important thing
is to be absolutely,
totally honest with clients.
I've been in situations
where my boss, you know,
at times in my job
would really want me to lie.
They'd say,
"Okay, the lie is...
This is what
we're gonna tell them."
And I would never
go along with that.
I've actually been fired
for not going along with that.
But I think people are glad
to do business with me
once they learn that about me,
that I'm not
gonna fake them out.
Communicating clearly
is important.
I wish I were doing better
at it right now,
but, uh...
I think we've covered
that point.
I can give you, uh...
One important point
I want to make
from this slide...
And we heard it this morning.
You know, they were talking
about that Wave,
really cool stuff.
And we get to see it today
before it's, like,
even in an alpha release.
So, in my mind,
what I'm thinking is,
"Oh, this is great.
"I can be ready
when our customers arrive.
"I'll--I'll be prepared.
"I'll understand how to do it,
how to work with it."
So the point is,
figure out what
your customers need next year
and start
preparing for that now.
The point about learning
what the market will bear
and bid at or just below that--
just a quick point--
I don't want to be
the lowest bidder,
unless it's
a government project.
I'd rather be
the preferred bidder.
Which projects to tackle?
As work starts to, uh...
As you start to get more
opportunities to bid on work,
you have to decide what
you really want to go after
and what you don't.
So kind of the questions
we would go through--
"Is this project
in our niche?"
Meaning, we're gonna give it--
if it is,
we're gonna give it
the most aggressive price
and the shortest lead time.
It's something--
You know, we know how to do it,
and we can do it as well
or better than anybody else.
If the project
is close to what we--
close to our niche,
in the neighborhood,
then it's similar.
You know, we'll try to come in
with a really good price
and a decent lead time.
If it's something we'd
really like to start doing,
you could consider
buying the business,
you know,
almost give it away,
just to get the experience
at doing it.
And some projects,
if you see there's something
frightening about it,
sometimes it's hard
to tell the client,
"No, I don't want
to bid on that."
It depends on your
relationship with them,
but you may not be
in a position
where it's comfortable
to say no,
so what we've done at times is
maybe say, "Okay, yes,
but we'll bid just
on this part of the project."
Or, "Yes, but here's
our price."
And the price is set such that
if we do get it, okay.
We won't mind too much.
I don't know.
You know,
everybody here, I guess,
you know, you have a job,
you're working for somebody,
or maybe you're working
for yourself.
Somebody we'll call
an astute observer of patterns
pointed this set of transitions
out to me.
You know, starting off,
you're, like, somebody
that's just a programmer,
doing things because
they're interesting or fun.
At that stage,
you don't want to worry so much
about the monetization angle.
You know, you make money
accidentally,
or if you have to somehow,
you know, through AdSense
or whatever.
Then, as a developer,
you start to do things
where some problem
you have solved,
because it was interesting,
that solution you provided
will help somebody else,
and they'll be willing to pay
for that solution.
So in those,
you can start picking up
some momentum that way.
Then once you've done that
for a while,
you feel like, "Okay,
this is getting more serious."
And it becomes very important
to cultivate repeat business
at that point.
I want to tell one story.
I was working with a client,
and they fielded, like,
five different Gadget ads,
you know, kind of all across
the map possibilities.
And they ran those
for about a month,
and then they picked
one winner of the five
and said, "Okay,
we're gonna go with this one."
And then they ran it
for about a month,
and they decided
they wanted to make a change.
The way their ads
were structured,
there was four different topics
and, uh...
eight different sizes,
so the change they needed
was gonna hit
32 different places.
So they wrote an email,
you know,
"How long is this gonna take?
How much is it gonna cost?
Is it difficult?"
And the actual change
they needed
was one of those
one-line-of-code-type changes.
And I responded, I said,
"It's done. No charge."
You know,
it took about a minute.
And I already had
a program in place
to handle the repetitive stuff.
And I think they were shocked
that that was the answer.
"It's done,
and there's no charge?"
And what they learned
about us at that point
was--is that we weren't
gonna take advantage of them
on some little something.
They believe us when we say--
And so now when we say,
"That change is gonna cost
several thousand dollars,"
they believe it,
'cause they know we're
gonna tell them the truth
about the ones
that are really trivial.
And they've become
our second-biggest customer.
And actually,
I think if anybody else--
IBM or whoever, you know--
went to them and said,
"Okay, we can do
what Echo3 is doing,"
it'd be a really
hard sell for them.
You know, we've really
developed some loyalty.
This is kind of a short list
of some lessons learned.
The example I just gave,
using software
to automate repetitive tasks,
you can see
where that helped.
And we told the story
about looking out
for open-ended statements
and requirements.
One way I shoot myself
in the foot,
I try to turn things around
really quickly.
Recently, I published
a really big bug
in kind of
a high-profile project,
and you know what?
It tested, it looked okay
and everything,
but I realized I was looking
at some cached results.
And so, anyway,
there's no such thing
as too much testing.
Sometimes with clients,
you know,
they'll want to,
say, do a new ad,
and they want
to talk about it on the phone,
and while you're talking--
you haven't even seen
a mock-up yet.
"Can you give me
a quick estimate?
You know, some kind
of ballpark thing?"
So one thing I found is,
if I think something's
gonna take me three days,
I should say six days.
And if they want to say,
"Well, worse case."
So for me,
I multiply that by four.
And the last part--
they told me to use a picture.
One thing I found, I think
I've blown some business
by using rough drafts.
I don't have any problem
with a rough draft.
You know, "I get it.
Okay, yeah, the images
will look better later."
And,
"We're gonna have somebody
that's really good with graphics
come back and do this."
But one lesson learned
is use a wire frame.
Some people just aren't--
they're not gonna play with you.
They're not
gonna be that imaginative
about how this might look.
And the big warm-up
for Jerome coming up now,
you'll be glad to hear.
Talking about Gadget ads
a lot.
These are some of the typical
Gadget ad features,
that they're contextual...
And I'm sure everybody here
understands that concept.
Geo-awareness
is becoming more and more
important with ads.
I'm not supposed to mention
certain client names,
but, for example,
there's one very large
online auction company
that sells cars online,
and they, of course,
you know,
when somebody buys a car,
they don't want to drive
six hours to pick it up.
They want something
in their location.
So, uh...
the ads
from the AdWords network
are given these parameters--
city, region,
or latitude and longitude.
It's getting easier and easier
to find out where the user is.
Gadget ads typically
have to query a custom API
or Google Base
with--you know,
probably with a keyword,
and then obviously
it has to display something,
you know, the items, the image,
or where it's located.
And Jerome's gonna
take it from here, so...
Mouton:
Thank you, Michael.
So, yeah,
as Michael mentioned,
usually we cannot show or tell
what the customer ask.
The Google account team
for kayak.com
was nice enough to get us
permission to show you this one.
So as Michael mentioned--
And I'll use the mouse,
because pointing at both screens
will be difficult.
Oops.
Oh, don't start making--
Okay.
So this is a Gadget ad.
So, you know,
be a bit imaginative.
Picture that to be on a review
Website, for example.
You are on the Website
talking about museum in Paris,
and you have this banner ad
showing on top.
So as Michael mentioned,
we have the geoinformation
about where you, the user, is.
So in this case, we know you
are close to San Francisco,
so what the Gadget ad
is doing--
we find the closest airport
from a database
from where you are.
Probably that as a "From,"
a destination.
For the target destination,
you know, we have keywords
from the context of the page,
and here in this case,
it would trigger
that you're on a page
talking about Paris.
And with this information,
contextual data,
we can go and query
the kayak.com APIs
and find what other good deals
they have in their listing
with from and to Paris.
And what is pretty cool
with this type of work
is we provide them with value
to the user as well.
You are on the Website,
learning about Paris,
about, you know, cool stuff
you could do over there.
If we show you information
that you can get a ticket
for this price,
it's probably
some valuable data for you.
And, of course,
for the customer, for Kayak,
it's also very valuable,
because you're more likely
to interact with this type of ad
than with just some text
that is not really contextual.
So it's just an example.
We've been doing a couple
of design of those.
Again, if we were to tell you
about some of those,
we'd have to kill you,
so it would not be very pleasant
for this demonstration.
So Michael
discussed extensively
about what we've done
for concerting, contracting.
We've been also doing
different type of work
in the past few years,
and especially creating
our own products.
In fact,
that's how we started.
We've been very active
in the iGoogle scene,
creating gadgets for
your personalized home pages.
And when you do that,
what is pretty cool
is you don't have
a customer
telling you what to do.
It's, you know, your own idea
that you can implement.
You can be creative.
The issue, then, we want
to monetize on these ideas.
So the concept
is very different, right?
Nobody will be paying the bill
for you to develop the product,
so you have
to invest some time.
But it plays very well
when you're doing
concerting or contracting,
because you'll have
some downtime.
For some weeks, you won't have
any concerting to do.
That's a very good time
to reapply techniques
you learned
on customer projects,
or to learn
on new technologies
you can try
to do your own products.
So we discussed two main ways
of monetizing
using your ad networks
like AdSense,
which is pay-per-click,
PPC, and the other one
we look at as well
is using affiliate marketing
where you create some links
to some products
on some retail Website,
and you get paid
for customer action
if they buy something
or if they sign up
or something like that.
Okay, so let's focus first
on iGoogle
and what we've been
learning and doing
for these past few years.
The main issue
you have on iGoogle,
you don't have a full Web page
to play with.
You have a very small,
concentrated space,
and you are competing with
millions of gadgets all around,
so the best way to monetize
on the iGoogle Gadget
is to do that elsewhere.
In many situation,
you'll be doing a gadget
because you have a blog
or some content on a Website,
and you just want
to allow your users
to syndicate your content
and to see what you have new
when they visit iGoogle.
When you do that, you know,
the user will be, you know,
more reminded
about your content
through the day
when they visit iGoogle,
and you will get
some crazy traffic
from iGoogle to your site.
Something else
that is pretty cool with that
is once you have enough users
using your gadget,
and they are leaving good
comments about your gadget,
you will be ranked pretty good
in the directory,
meaning new users
will find your, you know,
your tool, your content,
and you're pretty likely
to get more users.
More users,
more traffic, more money.
So, yeah, again,
if you have a Website
where you can monetize,
let's take this approach.
Monetize on the full page
of your content of your blog,
and just do the gadget
to get some traffic.
We'll talk in a few seconds
about how to monetize
in a gadget,
which is more tricky.
But quick tips for iGoogle.
You know,
what we found works well
is don't try to do something
too big at first.
Try to find a niche,
and be good at doing
these little, small specialties.
And then
you can always expand.
That's always easy to do.
Something else
also to consider,
when you are just
starting development,
playing with these type
of technologies,
you know,
you're playing, right?
But once you start monetizing,
the users you will get
become your customers,
that thanks to these people,
you will be making some money,
so treat them as such,
you know?
Listen to what
they have to say.
Make sure that they have
a way to email you,
to contact you with
some feedback, some questions.
Also, you know,
you have to monitor
the Web pages and the directory
where they can
post comment and rating,
and try to, you know,
on a regular basis,
reply to that, you know.
If they have questions,
answer them.
If you have concerns or so,
address that.
I think it's very important
to be successful.
These users
are your customers,
so take good care of them.
So let's now discuss
about how to monetize
inside the gadget.
So we'll go through
a few examples.
This first one is one
of the first I developed.
It's a wall clock.
You know,
it became very popular.
On this one,
I've been using AdSense
as a way to monetize.
So, you know, AdSense,
the way it works,
it looks at the context,
the keywords around,
you know, the content,
and find something relevant.
If you've been using AdSense
on Websites
and you stop using AdSense
on a gadget,
you'll be probably
very shocked at first
to see the CTR,
the click through rate,
it's extremely low.
On the Website,
usually you see a few percent
of the impression
convert to a click.
On AdSense at first,
you know,
I was very surprised to see
that we have a number
of about 0.05%.
So, yeah,
it's very, very low.
But when you think about it,
it makes sense.
On iGoogle, you have
so much content on the page,
you don't have the user focused
on your specific gadget
all the time.
Even worse than that,
you know,
you can have
your gadget positioned
below, you know, the page.
You have to scroll down
to see it,
meaning most of the time,
the user won't see
your gadget or your ad.
Something else
to keep in mind as well,
most users,
they keep the iGoogle page
up all day long,
and you probably notice
that every seven or ten minutes,
the page refreshes by itself,
meaning you will generate
many, many impression
when nobody's
looking at the page.
So that's what explains
this low CTR.
So nothing
to be concerned about.
That's the way it is.
Okay.
Just to give you
some guidelines...
I don't know
if it's that useful,
but what we've been saying
for monetization,
you can expect to get
about 15 bucks per month
per thousand users.
When we talk
a thousand users,
you know,
it will be active users.
If you look
in your analytics account,
you know, they show you
the evolution per day.
Kind of takes the peak,
and you can assume that the peak
is your active user base.
Okay?
This number is, of course,
it's a ballpark figure.
If you have a gadget
with some content
that match very
high-paying keywords,
you may see something
better than we do.
Good for you.
But some--
I think some people,
as you can see,
something less than that.
It's just probably an average.
All right.
Google released
not that long ago
the canvas view for iGoogle.
So that's a pretty
powerful feature.
If you have a gadget
and need more space,
you can define
an alternate view,
which will be using
kind of a full page.
You still have
the Google logo on top
and a sidebar
on the left-hand side,
but you have much more
real estate to play with.
That's an example
from LabPixies.
It's one of the top
developers for iGoogle,
and they've made
very good use of that.
They have a little game
that on the iGoogle page
is just a small image.
You cannot
do anything with it.
But when you click on it,
it opens a full-time view--
full-screen view,
and they show you the game
plus some big-size ad
on the side.
We can implement that,
continue with that user.
You know,
but I'm pretty sure
it's working
pretty well for them.
It's probably about, you know,
the same as a Web page.
On the other hand,
the user will see the ad
only when they interact
with the gadget.
So we're pretty much back
to when you have a gadget
driving traffic
to your Website.
Another example
I wanted to show you
is using affiliate links.
So it's a small gadget
that's designed
just for fun at first.
I'm a big fan of woot.com.
I like to see every day,
every morning,
what they are selling,
so I designed this small gadget,
and it started working
pretty well,
so I was thinking,
"How can I monetize?"
And at the time,
I already had the wall clocks
with AdSense.
And even though
it was working well,
I was still getting,
you know,
weekly hate emails from users,
saying, you know,
"It's dirty. Don't put AdSense
on iGoogle," you know.
People don't like it
that much.
Of course,
it takes up real estate.
So I wanted to experiment
with something different.
You know, I thought
because woot.com customer,
I know them pretty well.
They are in the U.S.
They are people
who like technologies.
If I can show you
some product
on Amazon, buy.com,
or you name it,
they'll probably be interested.
You know, if I find
the good deals of the moment,
that will be
good value for them.
So I started building that
manually every day,
finding products
and putting links up there.
And these links are created
through their affiliate Website
of, you know, as I mentioned,
Amazon or others.
So when someone
click on the link,
and if the customer later on
buy a product on the site
I'm sending them to,
we get a commission
ranging from 1% to 8%,
roughly.
What is, you know,
I think
is a good takeaway from that
is I never had anybody
complain about this type
of advertising in a gadget.
It's small.
It's looking pretty nice.
So--But two years
I've been doing that,
and never receive
a single email from anybody.
On the other hand,
the revenue
is not as good either.
You know,
doing this type of work,
I'm getting about $2 to $3
per month per thousand users.
But I think, you know,
at least the look and feel
is good, and the user are happy,
so I think
it's a good drawback.
If you want to try to play
with this type of stuff,
what I've seen amazon.com,
by far,
is what is paying the best
for affiliate marketing,
just because, you know,
most people will buy something
from Amazon, so...
If you send them
to other smaller Website
like buy.com, newegg.com,
TigerDirect,
and a few of the bunch,
the conversions aren't as good.
And so by the way,
Amazon, they have
their own affiliate program.
If you want to go
and affiliate with the others,
you have to use brokers
like Commission Junction,
CJ,
linkshare.com as well
is on the brokers.
And I'm talking here
about technology products.
But if your site
is about babies
or about, you know, fashion,
you know,
they have affiliate programs
with almost any type
of retailers.
I was planning to have time
to experiment
before I/O something new,
but I did not.
Something
I would like to play with,
Zanox, is another one of these
brokers for affiliate.
They just released
a few weeks ago
what they call
the Zanox Web Services.
It's a nice API that seems
to allow you to get products
based on some searches
you're doing.
Meaning you can rotate products
automatically
through their system.
Just right now
what I'm doing is,
I'm pooling
all the best sellers
from a bunch of retailers,
and then
I'm picking random products
to make them rotate
every 12 minutes
to make sure, you know--
I try to get people interest.
Okay?
So we talked
about iGoogle so far.
Everything we discussed about
applies as well
to OpenSocial applications.
OpenSocial
is pretty much gadgets
running on social Website,
like, you know, MySpace,
the orkut, the hi5,
and you name it.
The only difference,
I think, that you will face
is each social container
has its own policies
and type of services,
'cause they
will tell you exactly,
you know, what you cannot do
or what you can do,
and you have to spend
quite some time
with this document,
because, you know,
they are pretty extensive.
The common ground is
you will not be able to put ads
on what they call
the profile view.
The profile view,
they say it's a user property.
You cannot put anything there.
You can only monetize
in what they call
the canvas view,
when it's in full screen.
But here, again,
you can use AdSense
or affiliate marketing
or anything you would like.
Okay.
Let me see where we are.
Yeah, I wanted
to show you something
that I think it's interesting.
First,
it's pretty nice-looking.
So it's, over a year,
the evolution of AdSense,
you know, for some gadget.
The blue color show you
the daily page views.
So you see it's a pretty nice
gross in average.
In red,
I'm showing the evolution
of the click-through rate.
So as you can see,
it's not moving exactly the same
as the number of views per day.
And in green at the bottom,
I'm showing the evolution
of the daily earnings.
I think it's interesting,
because you would expect that
to correlate pretty well,
and it's not the case at all.
You know, this curve
move in all direction
kind of by themself.
So what I want
to point out here
is don't have too much
expectation, you know.
You will get, you know,
what they give you,
but you will be
facing situation
where there will be
maybe no ad available
for the keywords
of your content at some point,
which mean that
you will see a drop in revenue,
or there will be
no high-paying ads
available to you,
but you will get,
you know, low-paying one.
Maybe it would appeal more
to your user,
meaning more clicks
and less money.
Something else
we've seen as well,
and it was pretty unfortunate,
at some point for--
It lasted a few weeks.
There was a pretty
bad bug in AdSense,
and for my U.S. customers,
they were seeing ads
in Chinese,
German, you know,
and other foreign languages.
So as you can bet, you know,
you don't get
nice conversion with that.
If they cannot read
what you are showing to them,
they won't click on it.
So, you know,
just keep it in mind.
It's--yeah.
It won't be a steady growth
when you go through more users.
Let's talk a little bit
about maps,
because that's an API
where Google is, you know,
number one for mapping.
Also if you do any mashups,
or any Website
where you want to show
location-based information,
you will be most likely
using Google Maps.
They just released something,
and I believe it's still
in beta right now,
but it seems to be
very interesting.
As of today,
if you want to monetize
on a site with maps,
you have to put banners
outside the map.
You're losing some real estate,
because you could have
made the map bigger,
and also
it's pretty difficult
for AdSense to pick up
what the content
is talking about, you know.
A map is just, you know,
graphic information.
There is no real keyword
to latch on.
What they are releasing,
it's map ad units,
so this time,
the ad are showing up
inside the map area.
You can see that on the corner,
right corner here.
I will stop touching.
Okay.
Not only, you know,
you don't lose real estate,
but better than that,
the ad content
is using the geolocation,
so as you pan through the map,
they will get new content
which is relevant
to where you are,
what is the location
you are looking at.
So what we heard is
they've seen people
in the better program
seeing the ad revenues
going up ten times
by just moving the ad
from outside
to inside the map.
That's pretty promising,
so I'm looking forward
to trying that very soon.
Another thing
they just released,
and I don't have a slide yet,
is they offer,
or they will offer,
a new overlay,
which they call the Google bar.
And it's a new overlay
that you will put
on the lower left corner,
and which give you the ability
to add a search box
in the map.
And if someone search
in this search box,
land to a page of results,
and then if they click on
the affiliate link from Google,
you will get a commission.
That's many "if," right?
But, yeah,
it's something small
that won't take much space
on your map,
and which may lead
to some additional revenue.
All right.
We talked
about quite a few stuff--
gadget, applications,
and monetization.
All these stuff
are still pretty small project
that you can put together
in a few days.
If you have a bigger idea,
you know, you have a pretty nice
Web application
you think you would like
to develop,
and make it, like,
a new start-up
to do a real product
that maybe you will sell
or something,
what was difficult
a few years ago,
is you had to shell out
quite some money
to get started.
You had to rent, you know,
hardware
or rent virtual servers.
You had to pay development--
environment and stuff.
What is very good for us today
is we have all these
great communities from Google
available without paying
a penny, right?
For hosting,
now we have App Engine
with Java or Python.
As long as you are
in the ramp up mode,
you won't pay anything,
because, you know,
you have free quota,
which let you
do pretty much,
you know, let you
go a long way already.
Hosting videos
can be extremely difficult
and expensive,
because it's large data,
a lot of bandwidth,
and, you know, YouTube
help you a long way with that.
And same for GWT.
You know,
as was many station
doing these
past two days about GWT,
very great AJAX framework
that let you do cool stuff.
We talk about Maps,
Auth, and many others.
And I can't, you know--
I can't really testify
about that.
I'm just in the process
we started a few months ago
to create a new start-up.
Nice T-shirt here.
TeamZone.
It's a video discussion solution
for private discussion.
We want to enable remote teams
to better collaborate
with recorded conversations.
So we went through that,
and it help us a long way
to get something running
without, you know,
kicking out any big bucks
to start with.
So something I wanted to add
before I hand back the mic
to Michael,
what has been
very useful for us,
to start with with Michael,
when we first did
some Google Gadgets
and stuff like that before
to give some clients,
is participating
in the Google groups.
So I'm sure you know that
every single Google technology,
they have their own
Google group
for people to ask question
and, you know, to get some help.
I think it's very important
that if you are serious
about that, spend some time.
Learn from this group
to start with.
Ask questions.
And as you grow
and you learn some,
you know,
you get some expertise,
start giving back
to the community
and helping them as well.
You know,
start answering question
and showing that you are
an active participant.
That's the best way,
you know,
to show the world that you
are an expert in this area.
They have a ranking system
where, you know,
people can put you stars,
and, you know, you'll get
more visible in the group.
We had many clients contact us
because they've seen us
in these groups
as active participant,
and also, Google,
sometimes, you know,
they name the API gurus
for these groups,
and it's very good.
You'll see
some customers sometime
posting some request
for codes.
They say, "Okay,
I would like to do this.
Contact me and let me know
how much it will cost."
So, yeah, I think
it's very important.
It's something you want
to look at definitely
if you are serious
about doing business
around these technologies.
And I think that's it for me.
Michael, back to you.
[applause]
Thompson:
Well, it's almost over.
Okay.
Again,
the idea of this talk
was for people interested
in building a business.
And the whole question is,
is the business you build
sustainable?
You know,
not everybody's cut out
to have their own business.
I'm kind of stubborn,
and I don't like people
telling me what to do,
different things like that.
I don't mind working by myself.
So not everybody
has those characteristics.
Where I live,
the bank's
right across the street.
They know me.
If I wanted to go borrow money
to start a business,
they'd loan it to me,
as long
as I'm willing to put up
60% of my own personal assets
as collateral.
But it's not for everybody.
If I did go for a loan--
I didn't have to for this,
but if I did,
there'd be forms and questions,
and let's see the business plan
and all those sorts of things.
But it all boils down to,
is this business
going to be sustainable?
And, for me,
the definition of sustainable
is it keeps meeting
the break-even point.
I generate enough sales
to cover the cost
of doing business,
plus a living for you
and any employees
you might have.
So the real question, then,
in any business venture
you're thinking about starting
will be, "Will the business
"provide enough value
"to keep customers
paying as much or more
as your break-even point
from now on?"
That was the point of the talk,
and thank you so much
for your patience.
I wish I was a better speaker.
But I appreciate
you hanging in there with us.
And I guess if anybody
had a question,
this would be the time.
[applause]
It's okay
if you don't have questions.
Mouton: Yes.
man: Could you
go back to the slide
that had the statistics
of the earnings?
Thompson: Yeah.
man: Where you have
your increase there--
red goes up,
money goes down...
Mouton: Yes?
man: Do you think
that's a result
of the people
who place the ads
cut back on the amount
that they put in
due to the fact that they're
getting excessive clicks,
so they're spending
through their budgets
before they get
any decent returns?
Mouton:
That could be one explanation.
The other thing is maybe,
you know,
one advertiser
was paying a lot of money,
just had no budget anymore,
and we are getting
different ads now,
which may be more appealing,
you know,
stuff that people are more
likely to be interested in,
but pay far less.
In this case, it would probably
pay four times less,
because we double the clicks,
and we get half the money.
Again,
we can try to explain,
but it won't help us out,
because the thing is,
it's a black box, you know.
So it's pragmatic
for you to get it,
you know,
and run with it.
Thompson:
Another way that can happen,
That could be
if somebody has a new campaign.
Like, I remember one time
an automotive company
started showing costs per--
paying for impressions
on one of my sites.
And I saw something
similar to that.
I kept checking into it.
I was seeing an ad
I didn't see before,
and I realized they were
paying not for clicks,
but just for impressions.
It could just be somebody
had a big campaign.
man: Thank you.
Mouton:
Any other question?
Yes, please.
man: Just curious
what your thoughts would be,
you know, if, let's say,
if, like, a two-developer team
is there,
and they're creating gadgets
for either iGoogle
versus a social network.
You know,
so what'll be the ROI
if you were to compare,
you know,
"We have X number of hours
to put in."
You know, "Which way
would we rather go--
"create little gadgets
for social networks,
versus, you know,
an iGoogle?"
Mouton:
Okay, my take on that is
if you're
starting something today,
you'll have a bigger reach
on social networks.
You know, iGoogle,
we're talking about
tens of millions of people.
With social network,
we're talking about hundreds
of million of people, right?
With little more work,
you can move an application
you've done for MySpace,
you can move it to hi5,
to, you know,
to millions of places.
So, yeah, if you are
starting something today,
think social.
That's where you should be.
For us, when we started
four years ago,
iGoogle was the place to be.
man: So you are entering
in that space now?
Mouton:
Yes. Yes, yes.
man:
Okay. Thanks.
Mouton:
But on the other hand,
as I mentioned, OpenSocial is,
in my opinion,
a superset of the iGoogle.
So if you can do both,
you know, do it, right?
You know, the more places
you're seeding your application,
the better reach you will have.
man: Thanks.
Mouton:
You're welcome. Yeah.
All right.
If there's another question,
you can still find us around
at the conference,
and, yeah, we'll be very,
you know,
pleased to talk to you guys
about more details.
Thank you.
Thompson:
...Presentation.
[laughs]
Just kidding.